[MUSIC PLAYING]
AJ JACOBS: It's
great to be here.
I'm delighted.
And I'm going to talk
today about three
of my books-- so a
three for one deal.
And as David mentioned, they
all have this common theme
of self-experimentation,
trying to improve by testing.
And right before the
talk-- this is probably
not the way to start the talk.
But I was in the bathroom,
and the sign over the urinal
had a little slogan,
testing rocks--
so all about testing your code.
So I was like, I'm
in the right place.
The first book I
thought I'd discuss
was "The Year of
Living Biblically,"
and this came about
because I grew up
with no religion at all.
As I say in the
book, I'm Jewish,
but I'm Jewish in the same way
the Olive Garden is Italian
so not very.
But religion is such a
powerful force in society,
and I wanted to
know more about it.
Why are people attracted to it?
And I also had a son.
I wanted to know
what to teach him,
so I decided I'm going
to learn about religion.
I'm going to learn
about the Bible,
and I'm going to try to learn
about it from the inside
out by living it, by
following in the footsteps
of our ancestors, and actually
follow as literally as possible
every single rule in the Bible.
So that's what I did.
I got a board of
spiritual advisors,
so I got rabbis, and ministers,
and atheists, and scholars.
And I bought a stack of
Bibles, and I read through.
And I wrote down every
piece of advice, every rule
that I could find in the Bible.
That turned out to
be quite a long list,
over 700 rules and
pieces of advice.
And I wanted to follow them
without picking and choosing.
I said, I'm going to
go for it completely.
So I wanted to follow the famous
ones like the 10 commandments.
Love your neighbor,
that's a solid one.
But I also wanted to follow
the less famous rules,
the obscure ones, that
don't get a lot of press.
The Bible says in Leviticus
that you should not
shave the corners of
your beard, and I didn't
know where the corners were.
So I thought I would just
grow the whole thing,
and that's what I
looked like at the end.
As you can see, some
serious topiary hanging
from my chin and sort
of a Kaczynski vibe.
And I did actually spend
quite a bit of time
at airport security.
That is true.
The Bible says that
you should not wear
clothes made of mixed fibers.
That's in Leviticus too.
And I thought it
seemed a little odd.
It seemed a little like God
was micromanaging there,
but I thought, I'm
going to follow it
because that's what it says.
The Bible says in the Hebrew
scriptures-- many times,
it says that you should stone
adulterers, and I thought, OK.
I should at least try.
And I was able to stone one.
I'll just give you an example.
It was in the
middle of the year,
and I was really
getting into it.
So I had--
I was wearing the robe and
the sandals as you can see.
The sheep, that I didn't have.
That was a rental sheep
just for the photo--
but everything else.
And I was in the park
here in New York,
and this man came up to me.
And he said, why are
you dressed like that?
And I explained, I'm trying to
follow every rule in the Bible
from the 10 commandments
to stoning adulterers.
And he said, well,
I'm an adulterer.
Are you going to stone me?
And I said, well, that
would be fantastic.
I said, thank you
for this offer.
And I took out a
handful of stones
that I had been carrying
around in my pocket for just
this opportunity,
and they were small.
They were pebbles.
So I showed it to him, and I
said, you know, it's not big.
He was very aggressive.
He grabbed the stones out of my
hand and threw them at my face,
so I thought an eye for an
eye is also in the Bible.
And I threw one back at him.
So that's how I
checked it off list.
Now at the end of the
year, I put down my stones.
I shaved my beard.
But I will say that there were
some life-changing insights I
got from this and
some takeaways,
and there are dozens of them.
But I'll just give you a couple.
One is the idea of gratitude,
because the Bible says
that you should be thankful.
So I took this literally,
and I was like,
I'm going to be
thankful for everything.
So I would press
the elevator button.
I'd be thankful
the elevator came.
I'd get in the elevator.
I'd be thankful it didn't
plummet to the basement
and break my collarbone.
So this is hundreds of times
a day I was being thankful,
and it was a
strange way to live.
But it was also wonderful,
because it really emphasized
the fact that hundreds of
things go right every day
that we take for granted, and
we focus on the three or four
that go wrong, or
at least I did.
So it's a radical
shift in perspective,
and actually it
inspired my next book
which I just finished
writing yesterday,
only eight months late.
So I'm proud of myself for that.
And that book, the
premise is I take
one of my great joys, my
morning cup of coffee,
and I try to thank every single
person who made it possible--
so the barista of course.
But I flew to South
America, and I thanked
the people who grew the beans--
you know, the people who--
the truck driver, the people who
made the truck, the people who
made the steel for the
truck, the people who
got the iron to make the steel.
And as David and I were talking
about, it's exponential.
So the idea is
there are thousands
of people that contribute
to every little thing we do,
and we take it for granted.
So it's, again,
about connection.
The second lesson
from this Bible book
was the power of action,
the power of behavior
to shape your thoughts.
There's a great quote
from the founder
of Habitat for Humanity.
He says, "it's easier
to act your way
into a new way of thinking
than to think your way
into a new way of acting."
It's sort of basic cognitive
behavioral psychology.
You act as if you're happy
or act as if you're kind,
and eventually your
mind will catch up.
For instance, compassion,
it's not an emotion
that comes naturally to me.
I have some but not
very strong, so I
had to build it up for this.
So I would-- my friend
was in the hospital.
I hate hospitals.
I didn't want to
go, but I was like,
what would a good person do?
What would a good friend do?
They would go.
So I forced myself to
visit the hospital,
and it tricked my mind.
I was like, oh, I'm in
the hospital visiting
a sick friend.
I must be quite compassionate.
And my mind-- you
do that enough,
and your mind catches up.
It's sort of the fake it
till you become it idea.
And then the final
takeaway I'll mention today
is the absurdity and delusion
of fundamentalist thinking,
because part of the
motivation for this book
was to expose the
absurdity of fundamentalism
by becoming the
ultimate fundamentalist
and taking the
Bible at its word.
Because I do find it disturbing
that, by some measure,
40% of America, millions
and millions of people,
say they take the
Bible literally,
and that's why they believe
homosexuality is a sin.
That's why they believe the
Earth is 5,000 years old.
I mean, this is a tremendous
number of Americans.
And it seemed to me they were
taking parts of the Bible
literally, but they
were very selective.
They were cherry picking,
and they were not
taking the bible literally.
They were not wearing--
avoiding clothes
made of mixed fibers.
So I wanted to show that if you
do take the Bible completely
literally, then you're going
to act like a crazy person,
and it is not a good idea.
And that we all have to
acknowledge that when
we engage in ancient
texts like this
that we are picking
and choosing,
and we are doing
cafeteria style religion.
We are cherry picking,
and that, listen--
that's fine if you pick
the right cherries.
If you pick the cherries
of compassion and loving
your neighbor, great,
but you can also
pick the rotten
cherries of hating
those who are not like you.
The second book I'll talk
about today was about--
was called "Drop Dead Healthy."
And so, this was not my spirit.
This was about the body.
And this came about
because for most of my life
I've been in terrible shape.
So I was what you call--
I wasn't traditionally fat.
I was sort of skinny fat,
so I looked like a snake
that had swallowed a goat.
And I got sick all the time
like, literally, every week.
And my wife said,
you know, I don't
want to be a widow in my 40s.
You've got to get in shape.
So I decided to do what
I did for the Bible book,
and I was going to test
out every single piece
of medical advice I could find.
I got a board of
medical advisors--
doctors, nutritionist,
trainers, geneticists.
And I wrote down every piece
of advice I could find--
again, even longer than
the Bible-- hundreds
of pieces of advice.
And from the next--
it was supposed to be a year,
but I was such a fixer upper,
it took at least two years.
So for the next two
years, I tried everything,
and it consumed my life.
Because if you're trying to
follow every piece of advice,
like there's no time.
You can't have a job.
You guys have to quit
Google, because there's
aerobic exercise,
anaerobic exercise,
you've got to
meditate every day.
There's huge evidence on
the benefits of meditation.
You should probably pet dogs.
There are some solid studies
that that reduces hypertension.
I didn't have a dog
at the time, so I
would go to the local dog park
and pet strangers' dogs which
was received with
mixed reactions
both from the owners and dogs.
You have to put on sunscreen.
If you follow the American
Dermatologist Association
recommendations, you should be
putting on sunscreen every two
hours, and you should
be putting on a shot
glass full of sunscreen.
That's like, my entire
salary would go to sunscreen.
You've got to prepare food.
We all know processed
food is terrible for you.
You've got to eat
food, and if you
follow some
recommendations, you should
take a long time
eating food, because we
are a nation of under chewers--
that we just wolf down our
food, and the danger of that
is that we'll over--
it's a sort of an
excuse to overeat.
Because as you
might have heard, it
takes 20 minutes for our stomach
to tell the brain that we're
full, so if you are
scarfing food down,
it doesn't have time
to send the message.
And you guys need to
redesign the human body.
That is-- it's got
some real problems.
So anyway, you should chew.
And I actually-- I found this
group, they are like hard core.
They call their
movement, Chewdaism.
I didn't make that
up, so don't blame me,
but they say you should
chew 100 times per mouthful.
So I tried this.
I mean, it's insane.
It's like it takes a day and
a half to eat a sandwich,
and I don't recommend it.
But I do think there is
some wisdom to chewing
more and slowing down our food.
Since I was a human guinea
pig, I tried everything.
I tested everything.
I tested-- I took a
sleep test, of course--
didn't get a great night's
sleep that night shockingly.
I tried every workout I
could find, including the--
this is the cave man workout.
The whole paleo thing
was just taking off,
so we went to Central
Park and threw boulders
and climbed trees.
And oh, I wrote the book
of course on a treadmill,
so it took me about--
I think it was--
I think it was about 2,500
miles about to, like, Arizona
or somewhere around there.
In the end, again, I did
not adopt everything.
I don't crawl around naked
in the woods anymore.
But again, as always
with my experiments,
I hope there is some takeaway,
some life-changing takeaway.
And for this one, to me,
the best health advice
is almost the simplest
health advice.
I mean, it is so
basic that it can
be summed up in a paragraph.
Like, most health books
should just be a paragraph.
And it's stuff you all know.
It's like, move more, eat less--
eat good food, real
food, not processed food.
Do the, you know--
don't smoke.
Don't hit yourself in
the head with an ax.
Like, it's very basic stuff.
There is some evidence for high
intensity interval training,
so if you're into that, do that.
But it's really quite
basic, and we all know it.
And the mystery to me is
why we don't act healthily
when we all know what
acting healthily is,
and that, to me, is
where you can find
some interesting insights in
how to motivate yourself--
how to sort of engineer
yourself to be more healthy.
And there were several
interesting strategies.
I'll just give you
one that works for me,
and that is it's this
idea of egonomics.
That's a term coined by
a Yale professor, who
talks about how we all
have two selves at least.
We have our present self who
wants to just hang out and eat
Cheetos on the couch,
and then you've
got your future self who
wants that present self
to get on a treadmill
or eat some salad.
So we've got these two
selves that are in conflict.
And one of the keys to
making better decisions
in every part of our life is to
try to remember our older self.
And I think of my older
self as some other person
that I want to treat well.
I want to treat that person
like I would treat a friend,
and you can do this visually.
And actually, you
guys can help me.
Because I did find some
digital aging software,
but it's not great.
So if you guys
have better ones--
so I printed that out,
and I put it over my desk.
And it does inspire
me sometimes.
I'll look at it, and I'll
be like, you know what?
I'm going to do this for
the older version of me, who
I want that guy to be around
to see my kids grow up
and, you know, get married
or not get married,
whatever they choose.
So that is just one of the ways.
It's all about how to
motivate yourself, I think,
as opposed to what is healthy?
Because people try to make a
lot of money by telling you
they have the secret bullet--
you know, the blood type
diet, whatever.
Dr. Oz has a new cure every
day, but really science
moves more slowly than that,
and we know what is healthy.
All right, so the final
book I want to talk about,
before opening it up to any
questions you might have,
is this one was started
about four years ago.
This started because I got a
very strange email from a man,
and he said, you
who don't know me,
but I am your eighth cousin.
And I thought, as
you might, that he
was going to ask me to wire
$10,000 to his Nigerian bank.
It seemed sketchy, but it
turns out he was legitimate.
And he is this man
who is obsessed
with helping to build these
family trees that are big.
They're not really trees.
They're forests.
They are massive interconnected
forests and not just thousands
of people, millions of people.
So it's a new--
I always thought genealogy--
kind of stodgy, sort
of in the needle point.
No offense to needle point.
Some people-- I once said
that, and people were
like, needle point's hip now.
Sorry.
But anyway, I just thought
it was a little stodgy.
But nowadays, it's
actually not at all,
and it's affecting every
part of our lives-- politics,
race relations, happiness--
because there are these
amazing revolutions,
technological revolutions,
going on in the field.
And there are two main ones.
One is these massive
family trees,
where you have millions
of people connected--
sort of a Wikipedia model.
You put up your tree, and you
can connect it to other trees
if you share a relative.
And it's almost
become-- it's like
the ultimate social network.
It's like six degrees
of Kevin Bacon,
but everyone's Kevin Bacon.
And you can connect to
almost anyone in the world.
Like, I'm on one tree.
It's got about 110
million, and I've
got my cousin
Barack Obama, who is
my fifth great aunt's
husband's brother's wife's
seventh great nephew.
So we're very close.
But the idea is, as again,
we are all connected.
And for the first
time in history,
we can actually see
how this is happening.
The other revolution,
as you probably know,
is genetic testing.
You can spit into a
tube, and send it off,
and get your ancestry
percentages allegedly
and a list of
hundreds of cousins
you never knew you had
and might not want to have
but there they are.
Now this, I was
fascinated by this,
and I thought this has to be
the topic of my next book.
And as I got into it,
what struck me was,
like all technology
revolutions, this
has the potential to do
tremendous good for society.
It also has potential to do
tremendous ill to society.
So let me quickly go over how I
think it could be great for us,
and then how it could
take a left turn
and take us down
some dark alleyways.
The way it could be good,
I think, is just a very--
first way is just the very
simple, almost childlike fact
that we're all one big family,
but now we can actually see it.
You can see it
concretely, and it makes--
it actually makes a difference.
And the hope is that
when we realize this,
we will treat each other
with a little more kindness
or at least a little
less horribleness.
And there is some empirical
evidence that this is true.
There was a Harvard
study a year ago,
where they took
Palestinians and Israelis,
and they told one
group that they were--
they showed them how they
were related, and the other,
they didn't.
And that test
group, that knew how
they were related to each
other, treated the other group
with more kindness.
They didn't buzz them as
loudly on a memory test,
so there is some evidence
that it might work,
this idea of we're
all family, then
we should be kinder
to each other.
I see it on a personal level.
This is not quite as profound
as Palestinians and Arabs,
but for instance, I always hated
Judge Judy, the personality.
I just thought
she was obnoxious,
and nasty, and not that smart.
But then I saw that
she's my eighth cousin,
and it actually had, rationally
or not, it had an effect.
I was like, oh,
she's not so bad.
She's just cousin Judy.
She's just doing a schtick.
She's probably a
sweetheart underneath.
And so, my hope is that this
Judge Judy effect will be good.
The second way I
hope it will be good
is that it will expose
this myth of racial purity.
And one of my advisors for
this was Henry Louis Gates,
the Harvard professor, and
that's one of his big themes--
is there's no such
thing as racial purity.
We are all a mix.
We are all mutts,
and that's good.
And there are some
interesting phenomena
happening, where white
supremacists take these tests,
and then they find
out, some of them,
that they have African-American
or Jewish heritage.
And the reactions
are mixed of course.
Some deny it.
They say, oh, 23andMe
is a big conspiracy,
a multicultural conspiracy.
But some actually have this
change of heart, and like, oh,
you know what?
My world view may
not be that accurate.
So the hope is that
this will increase.
And I, myself,
took all the tests.
I took six or seven of them.
They all reveal I
was mostly Jewish,
but they had different nuances.
One said, which was
interesting, I thought,
I am 97% Ashkenazi Jew
but 2.5% Egyptian-Arab.
So I liked having the Middle
East conflict in my body.
The final way I think
that it could be good
is that it could broaden
the idea of family,
because this idea of
the nuclear family,
the two parents and the
two kids, is actually not--
it's a pretty new concept.
When industrialization came
and people moved to the city
to be away from their
extended family,
that's when that idea that
this is the normal family
came about.
It's not really
the normal family.
And I like the idea of
broadening the family
to include gay marriage, sperm
donors, open adoption, even
group families.
And one of my favorite
stories in the book is--
I've found these twins,
separated at birth twins.
They were born in Korea.
They moved.
They were both adopted by
families in the United States,
and they didn't know
about each other.
But they had a mutual
acquaintance on Facebook
who said, you guys
look weirdly similar--
like, same freckles even.
And they got together,
and they took a DNA test.
It turned out they
were sisters, and it
blew their minds of course.
They tried to contact
their biological mom.
She didn't want anything
to do with it, which--
so that's the sad part.
The uplifting part,
to me, is that she--
one of the sisters told me I
feel like I have lots of moms.
I have an abundance of moms.
I've got my adoptive mom,
my twin's adoptive mom--
she's an actress, and so she
has what she calls a momager.
So this idea of reconceiving
family not just as strict DNA.
One writer says--
he calls it there's
your biological family
and your logical family.
And I think that's a good thing
to expand the idea of family,
because as my eighth cousin,
Hillary Clinton, said,
it takes a village.
All right, and then
quickly I'll end.
I like to end on a
down note on the ways
it could be terrible
for society.
So my main hope, of course, is
that it decreases tribalism,
which I think is one of the--
it's sort of the
problem of all problems,
because if we cannot
cooperate as a species,
we cannot solve these worldwide
problems like climate change.
So hopefully, it will
decrease, but there
is a chance it'll
do just the opposite
and increase tribalism.
I talked to one
sociologist at Princeton,
who, that's his greatest
fear-- is that these DNA tests,
everyone will get
their DNA tests
and go into their
own little silos,
their little ethnic silos.
And his nightmare scenario is
sort of a 23andMe meets Tinder.
So you like-- you know,
you're 72% Scandinavian.
You will only date
people who also are
70% Scandinavian and above--
and that it will
sort of turn the tide
against the decades long
trend of intermarriage
between groups.
So that is one
potential downside.
There is also--
I mean, it's going to be
psychologically traumatic
for some people, because an
estimated 2% of the world,
and that's a lot of people--
you guys are better at math,
so you know how much it is,
but that's a lot of people.
And 2% of those
are what are called
euphemistically
non-paternal events, which
means that their father
is someone else that they
don't know about.
And so, we're going to
see an increasing number.
The world is going
to be like one
big "Maury Povich" show as
people discover, more and more,
that they have a father.
And it all depends on how we
react to that information.
I have a chapter in my book
about a guy who, as an adult,
he has nine siblings.
He lived in the Midwest,
and they took DNA tests.
And it turned out every single
one of those nine siblings
was from a different
father, and the biological,
the assumed father,
was biologically
the dad of none of them--
so again, like "Maury
Povich" times exponentially.
And it was interesting,
the reaction,
because some of the
siblings were understandably
horrified and upset.
You know, my mother is a
tramp, et cetera, et cetera.
But some-- hey, the one
I interviewed actually
tried to reframe it and
be like, oh, this is nice.
I have all of these
new half siblings.
So it's a lot about how we
react to this information.
Oh, I will end.
Actually, I'm going to end on
a slightly more positive note,
because the book is partly about
explaining these revolutions.
Partly it's a memoir of my
own delightfully odd family.
I'm very grateful I
have a strange family.
And partly it's this adventure,
because this was about two
years ago, I decided--
since I have all these
cousins, I will try to put on--
why not have a party?
Why not have a family
reunion for all
of my seven billion cousins?
So I did invite seven billion.
We didn't get 100%
turnout, but we did get--
we got several thousand
in New York, about 4,000.
And there were 40
simultaneous reunions.
I called them the global family
reunion around the world.
It was the strangest day
of my life, very stressful.
I can never be a
event planner, but it
was the strangest cocktail
of humans, you know,
of all races and all countries.
And we had a
minister, and a rabbi,
and a Buddhist monk
onstage at one point.
We had, like,
D-list celebrities.
We actually had Sister Sledge
come and sing, "We are Family."
So we sang along to that.
And here are some images.
Oh, those are some
of my cousins.
Using these tools,
you can figure out
how you're related to pretty
much anyone, as I said.
So it's a very good
networking tool.
Like, I remember I called up--
there's Daniel Radcliffe,
and that was George HW Bush.
It is a remarkably useful--
it's like LinkedIn.
So I called up his press
person, and I said,
I'm writing a book about family.
I'd love to interview
President Bush since he's
had an influential family.
And she's like, well,
we're not really
doing any interviews anymore.
And I said, that's fine.
But just so he knows, and
you know, I'm his cousin.
And we are like fifth cousins.
He's my fifth cousin's aunt's--
and so, I went on.
And she was like, all right,
let me see what I can do.
So it actually
worked, and here is--
oh, here's some shots
of the reunion itself
in New York and some--
there's the Sister Sledge and
then some around the world.
So I will end it with that, but
I'm happy to talk about that.
I also have done a ton
of other experiments
that I'm happy to talk about.
I did one--
I was here like--
what is it now, three
or four years ago?
Because I did an experiment
with Google Glass.
I was one of the
first journalists
to wear Google Glass for,
I guess, a month or so.
And so, happy to
answer questions
about that or anything
else, but that was fun--
I had a great time.
Thank you for coming.
[APPLAUSE]
AUDIENCE: So for the
Bible year, how did you
resolve the contradictions
in the Bible
like turn the other cheek
versus an eye for an eye
and stuff like that?
AJ JACOBS: Yeah, that
is a very good question,
because there are a
lot of contradictions.
Because I believe, and I
said this in the book--
I didn't get in as much trouble
as I thought, but I said--
the Bible is very
much like Wikipedia.
It was written by dozens of
people over hundreds of years.
So when you say the
Bible says this.
The Bible says that.
What you really should be
saying is part of the Bible
says this, part of
the Bible says that.
And to resolve--
I could never resolve
the contradictions,
but I tried them both.
So I would try eye
for an eye, then
I would try turn
the other cheek.
I remember in terms
of parenting--
because some parts of the
Bible are be loving, and kind,
and compassionate.
But then there are
parts in the Proverbs
especially that, like,
if you're a parent,
you have to discipline your
kid physically and not just
with a hand.
You got to hit
them with a stick.
Like, that's what it says.
Do not spare the rod.
Hit your kids with a stick.
As you might have guessed,
I'm sort of this liberal Upper
West-sider.
I'm not so into hitting
my kids with a stick.
So the loophole I found was
I had this, like, Nerf stick.
And I would-- when my kid was
bad, I would, like, tap him.
He thought it was hilarious,
so he would run and get
a Wiffle bat and just
start wailing on me
with the Wiffle bat.
And I was like,
this is not working.
And I will say one
other difficult one was
the rules of purity, because
the Bible, as you might know,
in Leviticus, it says that you
should not touch a woman when
she's in her time of month.
And if you take it
really literally,
Leviticus says that you
should not sit on a seat
where a menstruating woman
has sat, because the seat has
become impure.
My wife found that offensive,
so she sat in every seat
in our apartment.
And I was forced to stand
for the year, which later,
as you saw, I did
this book on health.
And, you know, if you
believe some experts,
sitting is going to kill you.
Like, you'll all be
dead by the end of this,
because here we're sitting.
So it's actually a good thing
she made me stand for the year,
so I thank her.
Yes, sir?
AUDIENCE: It is
mentioned, your wife
and your child--
obviously, your family
had to go through this with you.
Is there anything that
they just absolutely
hated about the whole
process, and is there
anything on the flip side, that
they really liked about it?
AJ JACOBS: Oh, that's
a good question.
Well, it depends
on the experiment.
And I do get a lot of emails
saying that your wife is
a saint, and I
forward them to her,
so she knows that sometimes
the pain-- actually, you know,
it will pay off maybe.
But yeah, she hated
the menstruation law.
She hated the beard
for the Bible.
She wouldn't kiss me.
I did get-- this was
about five years ago.
I kept getting emails saying
you're putting your wife
through all this stuff.
You should do an
experiment where
you try to be the
greatest husband ever.
And I thought,
OK, I'll try that.
And it was kind of hellish.
I will say that.
And part of it was
what you would expect.
Part of it was like,
you know, the foot rubs,
all the cliches--
the Kate Hudson
movies, we saw those.
But part of it was
quite enlightening.
I'm trying to decide
which part to mention.
I mean, one thing that
I found enlightening
was it relates to what I was
mentioning earlier about how
behavior affects your thought.
So as part of my goal
to be the best husband,
every day I would buy her a
little gift, a little trinket,
just like $2 or $3--
like, you know, a
little soap that
smells like guava or whatever.
And I would present it to
her, and buying and presenting
a gift to her, it
sort of convinced me.
I'm like, wow, I must
really love this woman
that I am giving her
a gift every day.
And it made me love her more.
So that was--
I think that was-- and
I still try to do that.
I fail miserably, but I try.
And I will say just when
we're on the topic of my wife,
I did an article for "Esquire,"
it's about 10 years ago now,
where it was called, "Do I
Love my Wife, A Scientific
Investigation."
And the idea was
because there are
these scientists,
these neuroscientists
and anthropologists--
Helen Fisher is perhaps
the most famous--
who investigate the
science of love,
and what parts of
the brain light up.
So I thought it would be
interesting to see, you know,
do I love my wife?
And so, they put me
in an fMRI machine
and filmed my brain as
I thought about my wife,
and as I thought
about neutral people,
as I thought about Angelina
Jolie, and it was, you know,
terrifying.
It turns out I do love
my wife but only in two
of three ways, which, like,
after 10 years of marriage,
like 67%, I thought
was pretty good.
So I felt I felt OK with that.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Thank you
so much for coming.
I've read much a
bunch of your books.
So it's really nice
to see you in person.
AJ JACOBS: Oh, thank you.
AUDIENCE: I was
wondering if there's
anything from any
of the experience
you've done that you continue
doing that you never thought
that you would do, or that
you've adopted it in your life,
or maybe you've had other
people around you adopt.
So just curious like what's
become part of your actual--
AJ JACOBS: Sure, sure, sure--
well, I will say.
I mean, every-- ideally,
every one of these,
there's something I take away.
Otherwise, it would
be a waste of time.
So just to give you a
couple of random examples,
I mean, I still write
on the treadmill.
I still do like--
I go pretty slowly,
but I do do that.
From the religion, I
mentioned the gratitude.
I still try to practice that.
And I did join a synagogue, and
I do think there are benefits.
The way I-- just briefly
about religion, one scholar
breaks it up into the
three B's of religion.
There's belief, belonging, and
behavior-- so belief in God,
belonging to a community, and
behaving ethically or doing
these rituals.
So I actually think
that the second two B's
have helped my life.
Like, it's nice to
have a community.
There's lots of research
that a close knit friend
group is healthy.
The ethics, if they're
the right kind of ethics,
I think it's good to
reinforce them with a group.
I just never got into
the belief, the first B,
and I have become
increasingly worried
that to believe in
a supernatural being
can be used for evil.
So I've become increasingly
skeptical of the first B.
But I like the second two B's,
so those two B's are still
with me.
Yes, sir?
AUDIENCE: Thank you
so much as you are
sharing your stories with us.
Oh,
AJ JACOBS: My pleasure.
AUDIENCE: So you
made big changes
to your life-- big, big changes.
Do you think everyday
people understand
how much power
they have to change
the way they live their lives?
AJ JACOBS: Oh, that's
a lovely question.
Yeah, I do, you know-- if I do
preach the gospel that everyone
should experiment on
themselves, and it's right there
on the urinal in Google.
And I hope for gender equity.
It's on the back of the
stalls in the women's room.
AUDIENCE: It is.
AJ JACOBS: Oh, good.
I'm not going to check it out.
But I do think that
you don't have to--
I'm get to do this as
a job, so I'm lucky.
So I can do it as
radically as-- you know,
I can wear the crazy outfit,
but not everyone can.
But you can make
smaller experiments,
and I got a lot of feedback.
People say, you know, I tried
not to gossip for a week,
and that really changed my life.
Or I try not to lie--
or even changing
your toothpaste.
I did one experiment all
about cognitive biases
and trying to eliminate
all my cognitive biases,
which of course is
impossible, but you can try.
And one of the cognitive
biases was just
the routine of brushing
my teeth with Crest,
because I had always bought
it since I could remember.
But there is no rational
reason why I chose Crest.
So the experiment could be just
trying different toothpaste
until you find the one you
like best, and I used--
you know, Tom's has a delicious
apricot-flavored toothpaste,
which I much prefer.
It's made my life better,
just that little change.
So yes, I do preach the gospel
of self-experimentation.
Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, hello.
Thank you for coming.
AJ JACOBS: Oh, my pleasure.
AUDIENCE: I started reading your
book about becoming healthier,
and it was really interesting.
And it kind of made
me think that, you
know, there's a lot
of-- as you mentioned,
there's a lot of
different people
who go around saying that we
should do one thing or another,
and all these things are
sort of-- it does not work,
because as you point out, you
can't do everything, right?
AJ JACOBS: Right.
AUDIENCE: Is there any
effort to put together, like,
a sane set of
advice, like this is
what a normal person can do with
a set amount of time per day?
You know, like, trying to have
a really coherent set of health
advice?
AJ JACOBS: I like it.
I think you should write it.
I mean, I think that
the challenge with that
would be if you say you
have a magic bullet,
then that is exciting
and people buy it.
Like, they asked me to write
a health column for "Esquire,"
and I said, all
right, but it's not
going to be that interesting.
Because I'm going to write
the same paragraph every week,
which is, you
know, get exercise,
eat non-processed foods,
get a lot of sleep.
And then the second
month would be like,
OK, let me repeat this.
And then I could get even,
like, angrier and angrier.
It's like, how many times do
I have to tell you people?
Here is what you should do.
So I would say--
there are some good books.
Marion Nestle-- Marion
Nestle is a nutritionist
who has a good book
called "What to Eat."
I think you don't even need a
book on exercise, because aside
from the idea of--
I do think there is some
evidence that high intensity
interval training like going
really hard for two minutes
has some benefits,
but mostly it's
just do exercise--
you know, just
whatever you find pleasurable,
because you're never
going to do it if you
don't find it pleasurable.
So it could be gardening, it
could be building a stone wall,
or whatever.
So anyway, those
are my thoughts.
I mean, I think one of the
big problems with health right
now is the health media,
because of the biases built
into journalism, you want
the man bites dog story.
You want the-- if you
find one study that
says bacon is great for
you, that's the headline.
That's the article
you're going to write,
not the 980 studies that said
bacon is not good for you.
So it's this sort of unusual
study syndrome and flaw
that I think is super
dangerous, and that we
need more perspective.
There needs to be context.
I think of it as the Rotten
Tomatoes of health advice.
You know, you're
always going to find
a critic who loves "Battlestar
Earth," but 99% of them
are not.
So you're always going to
find a scientist who says--
with good credentials--
who says, you know,
that you should only eat
broccoli if you have blood
type, C. Is there a blood
type, C I don't think there--
blood type, B. But that is--
that is an outlier,
so you got to look
at what the mass of the
scientific community says
and go with that.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
AJ JACOBS: So there you go.
Anyone else?
Is there anyone else?
Yes, sir?
AUDIENCE: So do you have any
other experiments in mind.
"The Year of Living
Biblically," one of the points
of it you said
was to demonstrate
some of the dangers
of fundamentalism.
There's a lot of
other dangers that
have sort of taken root in
the last 10 to 15 years.
Any ideas for the year of
living without x or anything
like that?
AJ JACOBS: Well,
that's a good question.
I actually-- well,
I've got the--
I just finished the
one about gratitude,
which hopefully has this
message of connectivity that
might resonate.
And this one, I haven't even
written the book proposal,
so hopefully no one will watch
this and decide to scoop me.
But I am fascinated by how
do we know what's true,
and this whole fake
news phenomenon.
And basically, it would be a
book about epistemology, which
is a very sexy word, I know--
that's going to be--
it'll say a book about
epistemology, that's my title--
but it's sort of, you know,
how do we know what's true,
and how can we fight these
crazy biases and this sort
of this destruction of the
idea of an objective truth?
Because I believe it's
complicated, you know.
I don't believe in
black and white.
I think you always--
there's always-- it's
all about probabilities,
so it's hard to say, you know,
there is an objective truth.
But there is.
We just can't ever get to
it, but we have to try.
We have to try.
And that's, I think we're
losing that in today
in our crazy political world.
AUDIENCE: So I'm confused.
Isn't just I Googled it?
AJ JACOBS: That is
a good point, yeah.
I actually-- I'm
trying to think.
I did have a couple of
Google-related experiment
ideas, and I can't
remember what they are.
I mean, I did do the
one with the Google
Glass, which was fun.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: How do you
find like the willpower
and the discipline to
stick to your plans?
AJ JACOBS: That's
a good question.
I mean, partly, it's the
idea of faking it till you
make it and just like--
and partly it is--
I would say it's
delusional optimism.
It is a very useful
tool that I use.
So for instance like
with the health book,
I would wake up every morning,
you know, filled with despair
that this is such a huge topic.
How can I write
one book about it?
But then I would
pretend to be confident,
and I would act as
if I was confident.
So I would call my publisher,
and I'd be like, oh, this book,
I think it's going to be big.
Let's have a party
when it comes out,
where we serve kale martinis--
like the healthiest drinks
ever.
And then I would call
and set up a bunch
of interviews with doctors.
And by acting as if
I were confident,
after like three
or four hours, I
started to become a
little more confident.
And that helped
me from giving up.
It helped me prevent
So there it is, a little
delusional optimism,
not too much.
Because as we know, delusional
optimism has a huge downside.
Like, if you think, I've
never been in politics,
but I can be president.
That, shockingly enough, does
not work out, so there you go.
Yes, anyone else?
All right, well,
thank you very much.
I loved it.
Thank you again.
Have a good day.
[APPLAUSE]